Let's
go.
And now we're going to deal with the
seven churches. We've already seen that
we are supposed to read it in a historic
continuous way. Blessed is he that
readeth and that hear the word of the
prophecy and keep the things that are
written therein. For the time is at
hand. Revelation 1:3. The time is for
each time in history. There was a time
at hand. And of course, particularly
for our time. I was in the spirit in the
Lord's day and heard behind me a great
voice as of a trumpet. And then we
looked at the great epinados in
Revelation chapter 1 telling us that
Jesus is the center of the whole book,
the whole Bible, that he is the great I
am. We looked at how in the book of
Genesis, man lost access to the tree of
life, death came in. He had to earn his
bread, lost dominion, became naked, and
was driven from God. And we looked in
the first chapter on how there was a
restoration to come in uh access to the
tree of life, victory over death, the
hidden mana, Jesus the one that would
take away the spiritual hunger for all
time, dominion was to be restored, white
clothes, and no more separation from
God. And then we had a small
introduction to the seven churches where
in Revelation 1 11 the seven churches
are named Ephesus, Smyrna, Pergamos,
Thathus, Sardis, Philadelphia, and Laia.
And I said that each one of these has a
very particular meaning. And we're going
to go through these seven time periods
as depicted in the book of Revelation
and given by the one who walks amongst
the seven golden candlesticks. So we
have a time period in the ministry of
Christ when he's in officiating in the
first chamber. So, we're not dealing
with uh esquetology events that happen
right at the end, but we have a
continuous sweep through history because
he is in the midst of the seven
candlesticks, one like the son of man.
And we also saw in that first chapter
very briefly that the seven churches
represent the old postal route starting
with Ephesus going to Smyrna, Pergamum,
Thatha, Sardis, Philadelphia and
Luditia. Isn't it amazing that that is
the sequence in which they occur and how
the postal route went and it's also the
sequence in which they are mentioned.
God is truly amazing.
Write the things which thou hast seen
then time application the things which
are
and the things which are hereafter
future application.
The mystery of the seven stars which
thou sourced in the right hand of the
seven golden st candlesticks. The seven
stars are the angels, the messengers if
you like of the seven churches. The
seven candlesticks which thou sawest are
the seven churches. So the church is the
medium through which Christ disseminates
the truth. So let's go to Turkey, Asia
Minor where we find these churches. This
is the city of Istanbul.
And here you'll find some of the most
beautiful mosques in the world.
You'll find remnants here of the great
battle between the religions, the
Ottoman Empire, great fort of the
Ottomans,
bridges over the Boserus,
marriages,
people living there today like they live
everywhere in the world. Everybody is
seeking a place in the sun. Everybody is
looking for someone to love. This is a
young couple that is engaged. She's
wearing pink here. And there's the coach
on top of one of the seven hills of
Istanbul Constantinople.
It's one of the cities with seven hills.
Rome is the other one with seven hills.
It's interesting that both were capitals
of the Roman Empire. And uh here is the
great blue mosque in Istanbul.
Tremendous building representing one of
the great religions of the world. And
we'll be dealing with some of these
issues as we go on in the book of
Revelation. This is S. Sophia.
Very interesting place. It's a museum
today. It used to be in Bzantine times.
It used to be a Christian church. When
the Muslims took over during the
postbazantine period, they changed it
into a mosque. And today it's a museum.
It's interesting that in this church,
they had the Christian reliefs painted
up against the walls. And when the
Muslims took over, they whitewashed
them. They just took whitewash and they
painted over them. And so they were gone
to the site. And now over the ages the
whitewash has faded. So when you walk
into the church you actually see the
Christian reliefs peeping through and
you see which is something which to me
is quite symbolic. It seems as if the
great barriers between the religions are
just coming down and uh they're sort of
blending into one and interesting time
that the world is facing. This is the
the uh underground channels where you
can do your shopping. It's very dark
down there. Of course, a very
interesting country. Turkey, one of the
great countries to visit. Excellent
facilities, beautiful food, third world,
first world, all in one. The great city
of Troy was then. So, it's the remnant
of that city. And uh this is what's left
of the town of Trrowaz.
This is where Paul preached one night
and he must have been uh uh a tedious
preacher who kept on for hours and hours
such as myself because poor old Uticus
couldn't take it anymore. Fell asleep
like they sometimes do in mine to
crashed down from the window and broke
his neck and the miracle took place
where Paul prayed over him and he was
healed. This was the place. Today it's
just a little harbor place where
fishermen sort of launch their boats.
And uh this is where we have the setting
of the seven churches in this area. So
each of the seven churches where Christ
is represented as disseminating his
light to the world. Each of these names
have a particular meaning and they have
a prophetic meaning. There's a certain
character in each of these churches that
is described which applies to them at
that time and has a future application
into the future. Then the churches get a
commendation
something that they are doing right and
uh it's interesting that there is a
church that does not have a commendation
but we'll come to that later. Then there
is reproof.
And reproof is very important
because it tells us something about the
time period. Again, if you are being
reproved and ask to repent, is probation
then over? Yes or no? Obviously not.
Because if you can still repent after
reproof, well then probation cannot be
over. And so you cannot take this
prophecy and throw it into the future
after the close of probation. That would
do violence not only to the terminology
but would do violence to the structure
where it occurs. It is set by the
cayazma into the historic arm. Christ is
ministering in the holy place not in the
most holy. So this is a time period of
his ministry which does not pertain to
the time of the end although the
prophecy proceeds throughout the entire
Christian time even into that time. So
there's a reproof there's a council and
then there is a promise that's the basic
structure of all the letters to the
churches.
Now the first one is the town of Ephesus
was a very prosperous town. Today these
are the ruins of Ephesus. Here is the
great street of Curet. This is where
Paul must have walked when he ministered
in this particular town. And the name
Ephesus means desirable. So it's a
desirable condition to be in. This
church has something going for it. And
if it is the first in a period because
remember it says what is and what is to
come historic continuous until the end
of time because that's how God works. He
has concern for every generation. Then
it must be the first period of
Christianity.
And uh if we study the events, we can
put an arbitrary time on it probably to
about AD 100. And we can learn something
about the what is what it was like then
as it applies to the church in history
as well. Well, in Ephesus there was the
seat of Diana
and Diana was the mother of the gods.
This is where Paul had his great
argument about this very issue because
he said Jesus is the only way. And then
there was this big tumult
because they said no no he's putting
down Diana our goddess and uh they
wanted to take him to task.
So she was the mother of the gods. There
was a temple of Diana which was built in
480 BC. It's interesting that the the
Christian council the council of Ephesus
was held in this very town Ephesus and
there the title mother of God was given
to Mary. So there's some interesting
little correlations over there with the
seat of the mother of the gods and here
a title was given to Mary in this town
as well. So that's the setting of this
church.
Let's read the letter to the church.
Revelation 2 verse 1 to3. Unto the angel
of the church of Ephesus. Write these
things says he that holdeth the seven
stars in his right hand who walketh in
the midst of the seven golden
candlesticks. We've dealt with this text
already. I know thy works and thy labor
and thy patience
and how thou canst not bear them which
are evil. That's the commendation.
So Jesus is saying to them, I can see
what you're doing. I am happy with what
you are doing and you have discernment
between good and evil. And I has tried
them which say they are apostles. So
even in this early period there were
some who were trying to lead astray. Yes
or no? But they tried them. And what was
the standard whereby they discerned
whether they were from the good side or
the bad side must be the word of God.
That's the standard. How they you who
tried them and which say that they are
apostles and are not. So they were
deceivers and liars then in the early
church and we will see that in the
lectures that come
and has found them liars. How do you
find them liars? What standard do you
use to find them liars? Your feeling or
must you have something to base it on?
Surely you must have something to base
it on. the word of God and has borne and
has patience and for my name's sake has
labored and has not fainted. That's a
good commendation for the church at
Ephesus.
They still had their act together. But
there's a reproof. Nevertheless, I have
somewhat against thee because thou hast
left thy first love. So that first fire
that the church had, that fire that you
feel when you become converted and you
go off and you run to bring the message,
they had cooled down somewhat.
Remember therefore from whence thou art
fallen and repent, turn around and do
the first works. So complacency had set
in to an extent, but they knew right
from wrong. That was good. They worked
and labored for God. That was good. But
that firstborn zeal that was slightly
tainted.
Or else I will come unto thee quickly
and will remove thy candlestick out of
his place. So here it was a time period
that if a church did not live up to
whatever truth they had, then God would
do what?
take that candlestick away from them and
give it to someone else. Very important
point. So in this time period, we're
still dealing in a time in history that
if you don't live up to the light that
you have, God will eventually take the
light and give it to someone else to
carry it.
But this they hast
that thou hatest.
That's strange. God hates something
and he commends them for hating
something here. Hateth the deeds of the
niclatians
which I also hate. Huh? Remember now
this is a very important point. God
hates the deeds. Does he hate the
people? No. For God so loved the world
that he gave his only begotten son that
whosoever believeth in him should not
perish but have eternal life. God loves
people but he hates false systems of
worship. Can we get that point clear
tonight?
because we're going to talk about some
very serious things.
And I don't want you to get the
impression
that I'm talking against people.
I'm talking about systems. Will we all
understand that? If a system does not
preach truth but propagates error, then
God hates that system. Yes or no? Yes.
He loves truth and hates error. He loves
all people in spite of their mistakes
and faults.
Before we even knew that he existed,
he was willing to die for us. Right? We
must not forget that. So now they have
something for them and that is that they
hate the deeds of the nicolatians which
God also hates.
So the early church had the discernment
to hate the nicolatians. Well, who were
the niclatans? What were they? Nicolas,
nicolitan.
They were a group that taught they were
a sect, a gnostic sect that taught that
the law of God did not apply to man in
the flesh because man was spirit and
flesh. And therefore what he did in the
flesh did not apply to his spirituality.
It's a very common thought today as
well. So what the nicolatians taught
then they teach today. Nicolas was
Poseidon worship. It was the god of the
sea. The nicolitan.
Nicolas.
Nicolas. Have you heard that name today?
Yes, today we worship at the shrine of
Saint Nicholas.
You won't find him in history. You can
look it up in the Encyclopedia
Britannica. It says that he is a
fictitious individual probably from
Poseidon worship. Very interesting.
Jesus Christ
is God. Jesus Christ is savior. Jesus
Christ is the one who saves us. Now, we
celebrate his birthday on what day?
The 25th of December.
Now, the Bible says that the shepherds
were out on the fields. So, it couldn't
have been the 25th of December.
The god Zeus, his birthday was on the
25th of December.
The goddess Cyrus, his birthday was on
the 25th of December. I can go through
all the ancient gods,
the chief deities, had their birthday on
the 25th of December.
Now if Christmas,
which means Christ mass
was really the birthday of Christ, then
why are we celebrating Nicolas on that
particular day? Isn't it interesting?
And the kids are asked to ask whom for
their gifts?
Niculas.
and he rides through the sky just like
the ancient gods rode through the sky on
the 25th of December on a chariot drawn
if he was the us by a goat.
But if he happened to be a Nordic god
and we have a Nordic religion because
that's where we come from. We come from
the Goths.
Then he happened to be drawn by reindeer
and he could discern right from wrong.
He was eternal. He lived forever year to
year. He could tell which child was good
and which was not. He handed out the
gifts and there he went on the 25th of
December. And children today forget
about Jesus Christ and say father
Christmas.
Is that right or wrong?
So actually what we are celebrating is
Nicolas day and we love the Nikolaians
but the early church hated them not the
individuals but the system.
To him that overcometh will I give to
eat of the tree of life which is in the
midst of the paradise of God. Revelation
2 4-6.
Today, Christ is being supplanted by the
system in a little way, but it's much
worse than what it actually appears.
Here's the street of Curet, and this is
where Paul must have walked down. This
is where all the statues of the leading
figures of the town stood. And each one
had a head on. And if you had lots of
money, you had a sculptor make your head
and place it on there. And you paid
rents like you pay for your telephone or
whatever your house. And if you ran out
of money and defaulted on your payment,
off came your head and somebody else's
went on there who could pay the rent.
And so when you walked down there, there
you were in your full glory if you could
pay the rent.
Here was the temple to the emperor
Trojan. Temporal uh temp temples like
these of course were dedicated to many
gods. And the emperor
was of course the Roman emperor was a
deity. He was a reincarnation
of the sun gods. The town hall as it was
beautiful library in Ephesus. Temple of
Damition. Another emperor worship
another part of it. Then you had of
course the ancient scholastica of
figures here. Later on the Bzantine
church left its marks. And uh if you
were into plumbing, the plumbing was
good. These pipes lasted
throughout all this time. There was the
public toilet
and underneath there was a river so that
whatever happened was immediately
transported away. Nothing's changed. We
also have a river. We just pull a chain
to get it going. And uh there you sat
and you could chat to your neighbor
about whatever was happening in your
life. Here were the Scholastica baths,
the goddess Amus, the one with the many
breasts to feed the nations. And this
was the amphitheater in which all the
tumult took place. When the gold or the
silver smith who was responsible for
making all the statues of Diana got very
upset when Paul preached a different god
and uh the story goes that Paul escaped
from here. So this early church,
commendable church, it uh stuck to the
ways. It had discernment between good
and evil. It didn't allow pagan worship
to infiltrate into the church. They
discerned between right and wrong. Jesus
was the center of their religion. They
were a little bit complacent, but
otherwise pretty good. The first time
period was the same. Ephesus was a
harbor city and today there's no harbor.
In fact, the sea is many kilometers away
has been filled in by silt and about 800
AD it ceased to be a harbor city. It's
interesting in terms of time and
evolutionary sequences. uh this study in
Ephesus today, you find that Rome has
set up this structure which was
apparently seen in a vision as the place
where Mary lived because John came from
Ephesus and Jesus said, "Behold your
mother." And so he took her to live with
him in Ephesus. But this has been
determined to be a fake.
But nevertheless, this is where many
come to worship at the feet of Mary. All
religions come to worship there.
Catholic then we have pilgrimages of
Protestants even Islamic nations come to
that particular place. Well, the next
time period is Smyrna
100 probably to 313 AD because this was
a time period of tremendous persecution.
The word M is hidden hidden in the word
smirna and it means sweet smelling an
aroma of sacrifice. Now if you take the
city itself there was a shrine to the
goddess Nemesis. Polycarop was their
first minister and he was martyed.
Interesting. And in this depiction over
here we have a 10 days of persecution.
The Bible says take a day for a year.
Was there a period in the early church
history when there was
tremendous persecution
for about 10 years? And the answer is
yes. There was an emperor by the name of
Dialesian who decreed a persecution time
period which was very acute and ended in
AD. So from 303 to 313 when Constantine
put on the garb of Christianity
over his pagan body
and Christianity
became the official religion. So let's
have a read what it says here to this
particular church. And unto the angel of
the church in Smyrnina, write these
things says the first and the last which
was dead and is alive. I know thy works
and tribulation and poverty. So they
were having a tough time. The early
church grew very rapidly. Things were
going pretty well until this religion
started to challenge the official
religion and then persecution broke out.
And as soon as you challenge the
paradigms of the world,
persecution.
I know thy works, thy tribulation, thy
poverty, but thou art rich. And I know
the blasphemy of them which say they are
Jews. Christians. The early church used
the word Jews for Christians
interchangeably
and are not but are the synagogue of
Satan. So there are two churches on this
world. Those representing God and his
son and those representing another
power. Now this church has a
commendation here.
But there's no reproof, none whatsoever.
Fear none of those things which thou
shalt suffer. Behold, the devil shall
cast some of you in prison, and there
you may be tried and shall have
tribulation 10 days. There you have a
particular time period mentioned.
Dialesian persecution took that time
period. Be thou faithful unto death, and
I will give thee a crown of life.
There's the promise of restoration.
He that has an ear, let him hear what
the spirit says unto the churches. He
that overcomemeth shall not be hurt by
the second death. Interesting theology
there that we can deal with in later
lectures. Revelation 210-11.
So here is a church
no reproof. It's one of only two
churches in these seven churches that
has no reproof. only a commendation. So
this is very desirable.
But what did it take to get them like
that? Persecution. You see under times
of persecution
the dross is separated.
And what happens under persecution is
that those who are known for their form
of religion,
they fall away because it becomes too
painful to hold on to the form. So they
give it up. So if you really want to
stand in times of persecution, you
better be grounded on the rock. You
better know what you believe and why you
believe it. And that is why the book of
Revelation is very important because it
tells us that there will be a time of
trouble such as never was.
And we'd better believe what we believe
if we want to stand in that time. So was
there ever such a persecution? Was there
ever a dial? Well, I'll take you back to
that city of palms, Palmra
with this long Roman column as we saw it
in the previous lecture.
And uh here are the pillars of the bell
temple in the backgrounds and these
great arches. And as you go through that
city, you come to this board which says
Diolesian camp. Interesting. So this
emperor had his camp and his soldiers
here from where he conducted his
persecution of the early Christian
church. Very interesting. And this
persecution cleansed the church of all
hangers on for bread and fish.
But those who clung to the rock,
they were commended. So this was the
great Dialesian camp.
And modern Smyrna is called Ishmir. It's
quite a modern capital over there. This
is all that's left of ancient Smyrna.
Not much,
but it tells an interesting story in
time. These are young people laughing
and having fun in Smyrna like they have
everywhere else in the world. You know
what? I think God loves them. And God
would love them to have a full knowledge
of the truth as he would like you and me
to have a full knowledge of the truth.
But if you have truth and you stand for
it, this is what can happen.
Persecution. This is the coliseum where
they were p persecuted. Where Nero set
the Christians al light. He used them as
human tortures. They were fed to the
lions. Great suffering and death took
place here
as uh people were
destroyed
through hatred between religions.
Now you know that we are entering a very
interesting time in history today where
tension between religions is at fever
pitch. Have you noticed that?
And maybe the solution to the problem
which sounds so logical is not to be so
fanatical.
This it's so painful to be so fanatical.
Why not just, you know, compromise a
little bit and we can all get along?
That's true. I have no problem with
hundreds of religions in the world. But
as soon as you have a persecution
built into you that you want to destroy
anyone who believes other than you
believe, then you have a problem. But
what happens if they eventually say we
all come together
and we all pretend that we serve the
same God
and we'll have peace, final peace. Or
will we
peace to be found in compromise? Yes or
no? Well, that's the problem. You see,
the early church found that out. And so
persecution came and they were purged.
So when Satan could not destroy the
church under persecution,
when he set the one al light and 10 got
up to take the place because they saw
the faith of these people
who with love in their voices and songs
on their lips and prayers for those who
persecuted, not bombs,
prayers for those who persecuted them,
died for their faith.
others stood up and took their place.
And if that didn't work, what did he try
next?
Well, how about using the tactics of
Balum?
You see, Balam tried to curse God's
people.
Bailac wanted them cursed because they
were a threat to him.
But every time he tried to curse them,
what happened?
A blessing came out of his mouth. Big
problem. Big problem. Here were the
children of Israel and this prophet
Balam was asked for lots of money to
give them a curse, but they wouldn't.
And so he thought up a plan. And he
said, "You know what? If we can get them
to sin against God, then the protection
of God will be taken away and we can get
them.
So, let's try and get them to sin. So,
I'll tell you what we'll do. We'll call
a festival and we'll have a party, a
tremendous party with great music and
we'll worship the other girls and the
beautiful ladies.
They can put on their mini dresses just
for the night
and flash a little bit of leg.
And that's what they did. And what did
the Israelites do? They've been marching
in the desert. Their tongues were dry.
They looked at this and they said,
"Wow."
And they compromised.
And what happened? Terrible plague came
over Israel.
Well, let's see whether they
compromised. Peramos means elevation.
Lift up. Lift up what?
Lift up the self.
over the divine.
Have we heard today about self when you
switch on the television? Don't you hear
that? You have to find your strength in
your where?
Inside and you have to change yourself
from the inside and you have to do all
these things yourself. That's the new
way to salvation.
Pergamos lifting up man's way over God's
way and that is idolatry.
So the capital of the Roman province of
Asia there was a temple of Zeus
also of Esclippius the serpent god
man instructing serpent the healing
serpent wrapped around the pole. Do we
use that symbol today?
>> Yes. The medical world uses it today.
The proconsul
of Pergamos had a double-edged sword.
And it's very interesting that this city
was the bastion of the Babylonian
priesthood. You see, when Babylon had
been conquered by Meo Persia, they took
over the Babylonian religion. But the
priesthood revolted against Pergamum,
against Meo Persia. And so the
priesthood was driven out. And the
priesthood established itself here at
this city. So here was the official
ancient Babylonian priesthood.
Interesting.
They took the palladium stone, the
vestments, which were the vestments of
Dagon.
They had a fish robe and they had a fish
miter with an open mouth on their head.
Very interesting because they
represented Dagon, the god of the fish.
And he was called Pontifex Maximos,
the bridge between heaven and earth. So
you were saved by man's mediation, the
mediation of the church rather than the
mediation of Christ. So he was the
bridge between heaven and earth, the
keys and the miter with them. So he had
keys, two keys, the key to heaven and
the key to hell. Interesting.
And they were called Pontiff kings of
Pergamum. And the last one was Atalos
III.
Now he became a Christian.
Uh no not Atalos yet. Later they became
Christians. But Atalos III when he
realized that Rome was going to take
them by force. He bequeethed his title
to the Roman emperor. So if you go to
Rome today, you will see behind the
Roman emperors the letters PM pontifex
maximos
bridgebuilder. And the Roman emperor as
we saw were gods. So you could pray to
them. They were the one who opened
heaven for you. Now, it's interesting
that you will find those same letters PM
not only behind the names of the Roman
emperors, but you'll also find them
behind the names of whom?
The popes. You will find PM, Pontifix
Maximos. So this title came down in
history through the Roman emperors and
eventually also to the pontiffs of Rome
who by the way also have the two keys
which they refer to as the keys of Peter
and they have the same vestments
with the miter that represents Tigon.
How did that come into the Christian
church?
Now in AD 378 the Christian emperor
Gratan refused the title. So here were
the Roman emperors and here's one who
said no I don't want this title. So it
lay vacant until it was seized by
Damascus the bishop of Rome and this is
how the title came to be part and parcel
of the Roman pontiff. So we still have
the title today. But what happened here
at Paragamos?
Well, this was the time when this
compromise came in. Now at Paragamos,
you have this great great Paragamos
uh altar which was of course the altar
to the gods. All the gods of the
pantheon.
Tremendous battle is depicted here
between the forces of good and the
forces of evil. And Revelation 2
chapters 12 verses 12 to 14 say to the
angel of the church of Pergamos write
these things says he which has the sharp
sharp sword with the two edge. That's
the word of God. Jesus is writing about
the word of God. In here is another one
who also has a sword, but he is an
earthly mediation.
I know thy works and where thou
dwellest. He's talking to his church.
Remember, they're dwelling where?
Where? Satan's seat is. Wow. So, this
priesthood
which supposedes to be another Babel
portal to God
is an abomination of Satan.
Satan's cities and thou holdest fast my
name. So this church
still held to the truth in the midst of
these circumstances and has not denied
my faith even in the days when antipas a
very interesting name.
My faithful martyr who was slain amongst
you where Satan dwellers. Second time
that it says that. So here was someone
who was preferred preferred to die
rather than give up his faith and he
calls him Antipas. Now Antipas could be
some say a historic figure and some say
it is this one or that one or whatever
um pastor of that church was faithful at
that time. But the word antipas also
means antipontiff.
So it could be spiritual that this
individual who claimed to be the one who
mediated for you between God and man and
so mediation had moved from God Christ
to man that he was
a problem and people were commended for
being antipass
but I have a few things against thee.
Here's a reproof. Because there has
there in them that hold to the doctrine
of Balam.
Mhm. Who taught Bailac to cast the
stumbling block before the children of
Israel and to eat things sacrificed unto
idols and to commit fornication. So
something had been sneaking into the
church here because there are those that
hold to the doctrine of Balum. Now we've
discussed that. What was the doctrine of
Balum?
Compromise. get them to sin, get them to
break the law of God, and then we'll
have them. So, here is a compromise
coming in
where there is a doctrine being taught
which will lead the people astray and
they will start serving other gods.
And that's what's going to happen to the
Christian church. God is warning here.
Watch it.
Compromise is going to come. Constantine
did this. Constantine said, "Let's marry
the churches. Let's not have this
constant battle between Christianity and
paganism. Let's marry them." So, he
issued a medallion on which on the one
side he serves Jesus Christ and on the
other side he has his pagan deities.
But he had a problem.
Constantine had a problem. You know what
that was? The word of God.
Constantine had a problem with the word
of God because the word of God cut like
a double-edged sword.
And so what did he do? He said, "Let's
compromise."
I'm going to give a whole lecture on
this. And he got his priest
to rewrite portions of the Bible.
And he sent them out. And 50 copies were
made.
And they were written so that Jesus
Christ would become less than what he
was
so that there could be a marriage
between the religions and Zoroasta could
stand next to Jesus Christ and Zeus
could stand next to Jesus Christ and
Apollo could stand next to Jesus Christ
and everything would be honky dory. We
can worship them both.
It was an ecumenical document that he
commissioned. So a compromise came in
and Jesus had to become less and
obedience to God
was replaced by obedience to man.
Problem doctrine of Bal. So hast thou
also them that hold to the doctrine of
the nicolatians. Oops.
First they hated the doctrine of the
Niclatians. Now they held to the
doctrine. Repent or else I will come
unto thee quickly and will fight against
them with the sword of my mouth. He that
has an ear, let him hear what the spirit
says unto the churches. To him that
overcomemeth will I give to eat of the
hidden mana and will give him a white
stone and a stone a new name written
which no man knoweth saying saving he
that receiveth it. Compromise
is the greatest evil of all because it
is so deceptive.
It is so deceptive. Here is
this great city. These are the people
that live there today. The marketplace,
it is still third world, the red wall,
the outer wall, the temple of Dionisus,
the temple of Trojan, the temple of
Zeus. There is a well that Kaiser
Villhan made because he took everything
away and carried it away. Scholastica
and Sclepius.
That was the worship that came in in
Pergamos. Compromise.
I would like to recommend today
that compromise between error and truth
be rejected and Jesus and his truth be
made eternal in the hearts. Amen.
In our last section, we came as far as
Paragamos,
one of the seven churches, and we saw
how compromise had come into the church,
that now there were people actually who
held to the doctrine of the nicolatians,
whereas before they had totally rejected
it. Here you have a great amphitheater
still of that city and a well.
And uh the next time period is the
saddest time period in the history of
the church because once you have
accepted compromise
it grows like a cancer within the church
and it becomes total darkness.
So the next time period mentioned is
Tatha
AD 538 probably to 1517.
It has many meanings this name. It means
sweet saver of labor.
It means sacrifice of contrition
and some say that it also means Satan's
teachings. So after the compromise came
in and clearly we see that balams
technology
was used niclatians were acceptable
whereas the early church rejected that
teaching
here we have a time period of darkness
538 AD probably
the Justinian decree went out to appoint
the bishop of Rome as the corrector of
heretics. So now the word was no longer
the component which decided right from
wrong but a human individual had taken
the role of deciding for you what you
should believe. That's a problem.
Wouldn't you agree? If God created us
free agents and we individually have to
stand before God one day and give an
account for what we have done and what
we have believed.
Can we then say, "Oh, but he decided for
me." Yes or no?
No. What happened when Adam and Eve
sinned?
What's the first thing they did?
Blamed someone, right? Yes. When God
said to Adam, "What have you done?" What
did Adam say? "Who? The woman you gave
me was her fault." And when he looked at
the woman, what did she say? "Oh, it was
a serpent that begiled me." You remember
that? So once we start getting into that
mode, we start blaming someone else. You
know, we are living in a blame society
today. Have you not understand?
Nobody has a problem on this planet. No
child has a problem on the planet. I
have my problems because of my parents.
Have you heard that? My father was
exacting. My mother did this. This is
why I have the problem today. Nobody has
a problem. The problem comes from
someone else. The father you gave me is
the problem. Now sometimes it's true.
Sometimes the father is the problem. But
this is a trend in the world. Everybody
else is to blame. So here was now a
corrector of heretics. Here was someone
who decided for you what you had to
believe. And if you didn't do it his
way, what happened to you?
Sizzle fits.
That was the end of you. So it must be
this time period when man became the
standard for everyone else. It's called
the dark ages. Once you reject light
and you assume to be light,
that's when you have darkness. If the
son of God is not the light of the world
and someone else becomes the light of
the world, then you have darkness.
There's just no other way. So
Holtzhausal who is a Roman Catholic
theologian says it is the church of the
middle ages. Now in this particular city
you had a temple of Apollo that's the
sun god and you had an altar to a female
goddess. The church of the middle ages
had a god and they had deified a female.
We'll come to that later in the
lectures. There was a textile industry
in this particular city where they made
dyes purple and crimson dyes made from a
root known as madar root. Now the colors
purple and crimson are also the colors
of the church of the middle ages. Very
interesting. And the colors have very
particular meaning. Purple is the color
of royalty.
Crimson is the color of sacrifice.
So they have assumed the position of
royalty and sacrifice which should acrue
to none other than Jesus Christ. They
have set themselves up as the norm. They
are the ones who forgive sins. They are
the ones who says come unto me and I
will give you rest. Come unto me,
confess your sins to me and I will give
you absolution.
Whereas Jesus says
I am the way, the truth and the life.
Confess your sins to God. So here here
was a problem coming in.
Then in this story as it unfolds in the
city there's a story of Jezebel.
Now if you look in the old testament
Jezebel was the princess of Phoenicia
who married Ahab who was the king of
Israel and led the whole of Israel into
sun worship. You can read the story
there in 1 kings 18:4 2 Kings chapter
9:22.
Jezebel led the people of God into Baal
worship.
And you had in that time, if you read
the story, you had priests of Baal
and you had priests of Ashtaret.
Now, Ashtaret was the female deity that
was worshiped. So, you had a male deity
and a female deity. This is interesting.
And you could pray to either. And you
had priests of the one and priests of
the other. Now, the church of the Middle
Ages did exactly the same thing. You
have an entire priesthood dedicated
to Mary.
And you have a priesthood dedicated
to a male deity. It's interesting.
I know thy works and charity, love, and
service and faith. Remember that the
letter is written to God's church living
in those circumstances and sometimes
drinking from that fountain. That's the
sad part about it.
And thy patience and thy works and the
last to be more than the first. So
here's works orientation. Now let me not
get this wrong. There's nothing wrong
with works because faith without works
is dead. But if works take the place of
faith,
then your faith is dead. Are you with
me?
So here was a church that shifted the
emphasis from faith to works.
Notwithstanding, I have a few things
against thee. Because thou sufferest,
that means tolerates
that woman Jezebel.
Now there might have been a literal
Jezebel there. They say that in that
time period there was she was the woman
who was in control of the textile
industry who made the purple and the
crimson uh dyed cloths. But obviously
the Bible is using something literal
what was then and applies it in a future
application and applies it to this great
apostasy
which happened when Ahab who was king of
Israel
married
Jezebel. In other words, he went into a
relationship with paganism. Is that
clear? And here is this king who marries
into paganism. So the church of God
accepts paganism
and intermingles it into its very fiber.
So they suffer this woman. They tolerate
Jezebel which calls herself a
prophetess. Now to prophesy
means to preach. It also means to
receive visions and you have to take
from the context which one you're
dealing with. Obviously here they're
preaching
to teach and to seduce my servants to
commit fornication to become unfaithful
to God and to serve other gods.
And to eat things sacrificed unto idols.
Wow, that's getting pretty specific.
Idolatry and eating and drinking becomes
part of the idolatry. Now God had always
warned these people not to eat food
sacrificed to idols and here was a
specific idolatry.
It's interesting that the pagan deities
Bakus,
Zeus,
Osiris
were worshiped with round
wafer round breads
symbolizing
their bodies, literal bodies.
Did that come into the church system at
this time?
Well, it did. and I gave her space to
repent of her fornication. God gave her
time, lots of time to repent. But the
sad story is she repented
not.
And behold, I will cast her onto a bed,
and them that commit adultery with her
into great tribulation, except they
repent of their deeds. But they won't
repent. So this system won't change, it
will remain. So God will have to take
this light, give it to something else
because this system is not going to
repent. It's a problematic system
and I will kill her children with death.
So out of the system there will even be
children
who will be as apostate as she was. And
all the churches shall know that I am he
which searches the reigns and hearts.
And I will give unto every one of you
according to your works.
So if works is your criterium, I will
judge you by your works. If you lead
people into idolatry, I will judge you
by that.
But unto you, I say unto the rest in
Thatra, as many as have not this
doctrine. So not everybody followed
there came a great split in the church
and which have not known the depth of
Satan. Now this is interesting
technology
to know the depths of Satan means that
you must be initiated
into the secrets of occultism.
Is that right? There are people today
who claim to know the depths
of occultism.
And we'll have to find out where this
depths of occultism is seated today. And
we're going to do this in the lectures
that come in no uncertain terms. But
here it is seated in which church?
The church of the Middle Ages knows the
depths of Satan. Wow. That's scary.
We're going to have to deal with this as
they speak. I will put upon you none
other burden. So there are people that
resist this compromise,
that resist
this inner teaching, this mystery, this
occultism.
But that which you have already, hold
fast till I come. Here's the first
reference to the coming of Christ. So
obviously we've moved from a time period
when the church knew what truth was
became complacent
moved to a time when there was great
persecution and the church was cleansed.
Then a period of compromise,
paramos,
when truth and error became intermingled
to a time period when man sets himself
up as standard to decide right and wrong
and becomes religion for you rather than
the word. And then we get into
pure occultism.
Hold fast till I come. He that
overcomemeth and keepeth my works unto
the end, to him will I give power over
the nations.
Well, here is the Justinian
uh pillar. There it is. This one over
here commemorating the decree that man
can now decide who is
on the right side and not and has the
right to punish him even to death.
Pillars are brought in Egyptian pillars.
These are symbols, phallic symbols of
Osiris.
This is paganism. You will find them
particularly in Rome. Of course, right
in the center in the Vatican, you will
find this tremendous pillar of uh Tat
Moses III, the very pharaoh of the
Exodus. The triple crown which is from
Meo Persia represents actually God of
heaven, the earth, and the netherworld.
Wow, that's quite something to be
crowned with a crown that makes you king
of heaven, earth, and the nether world.
That's taking the place of someone else.
Well, obviously, we need some renewal.
The church of the middle ages became
darkness and it was known as the dark
ages. So the next time period is sardis
AD 1517 to 1798. It means renewal. The
time periods we will come to later as to
why these particular time periods are
relevant. Renewal that which remains
literally sad this means reformation.
Isn't that incredible that God should
have this in this sequence?
The city was impregnable
but was taken twice without resistance.
Once by Cyrus was king of Meo Persia and
Antiochus, Greek king Antiochus the
great. Let's read about this reformation
period. Revelation 3:1. unto the angel
of the church of Sardis, write these
things, says he that has the seven
spirits of God, and the seven stars, the
teachers in his hands, I know thy works,
that thou hast the name that thou livest
and are dead. Wow. Here was a renewal.
Here was new life in the church.
Something had been discovered. Idolatry
had been set aside. And there was life.
But this life was not complete enough to
make it life. There was death in it.
Be watchful.
Strengthen the things which remain
that are ready to die.
This is a terrible testimony.
So here was life coming and there were
things that had to be restored that were
dead that were now have to be restored
to life, but they're ready to die.
doctrines, teachings, for I have not
found thy works perfect, complete before
God. So obviously the reformation,
although it breathes new life into the
doctrine of Christ,
did not have perfect works. It was not
complete. Something was left undone.
It's very interesting that at the
council of Trent
there was a major major issue and we'll
be discussing this a little bit later in
the lectures.
The major issue was
solira
the Bible and the Bible alone as
standard. Rome said no
Bible and tradition
and tradition is the context in which
the word must be evaluated. So tradition
man is the one who supersedes and
controls the issues of the Bible. That
was the position of rock and man was the
one who determined how it should be
read. So the church decides what's right
and wrong for you, not the word. The
reformation said no. Solar script
solaria saved by grace and grace alone
saved by Jesus Christ and the word is
the standard whereby we live. That was
the issue. Who won at the Council of
Trent?
Good question.
Rome won. The Reformation lost at the
Council of Trent.
Sad. I'll show it to you in a future
lecture. The Reformation lost. A split
came. Yes, a split came, but the
Reformation lost. They had the greatest
opportunity in the history of the world
to complete the works and to win, but
they lost.
Why?
Because Rome could prove
that their traditions
superseded the word.
The reformation wasn't doing what it was
preaching. The reformation had said
solar scripta the word and the word
alone. And then the church asked,
"Do you keep all the teachings? Why do
you follow Rome in some issues and leave
the Bible alone?
Why did you set it aside? A cardinal got
up and made a speech. I'll come to it in
a future lecture. And say, why are you
accepting our tradition over the word?
You are transgressing your own precepts.
You mean nothing. You are just a
rebellion.
And the reformation lost on that issue.
It wasn't perfect before God. Sad story.
Remember therefore how thou hast
received and heard and hold fast and
repent.
If therefore thou shalt not watch, I
will come on thee as a thief, and thou
shalt not know what hour I will come
upon thee. That's a sad story, too. If
you reject light, sooner or later you
won't be able to discern the time you
are living in, and the coming of Christ
will be a total surprise.
Thou hast a few names even in Sardis
which have not defiled their garments.
So all was not wrong with the
reformation. The reformation was a
wonderful powerful tool. It just didn't
finish the job. It didn't go all the
way. The work was not complete before
God. And they shall walk with me in
white. I wonder who they are. Could it
be Yan Hus? Could it be Tindle? Could it
be White Cliffe? Could it be Martin
Luther? Could it be all those great
reformers? They are worthy. They stood
for what they understood to be truth. He
that overcomemeth the same shall be
clothed in white raignment, and I will
not blot his name out of the book of
life. But I will confess his name before
my father and before his angels. By the
way, this is an interesting text.
It doesn't say there, I will write his
name in the book of life. It says, "I
will not blot his name out of the book
of life." Wow. What's that tell you
about God?
How many people does God want to be
saved?
Everybody.
Did you know that every person ever born
was written in the book of life
and his choice decides whether he stays
there or goes. Sad story. Anyway, this
is Sardis, what it looked like. That's
all that's left from. This is a Muslim
lady
that accompanied us on that tour.
Wonderful
uh story. She accepted Christianity
and uh had to run for her life as a
consequence.
Anyway, here's an old Bzantine church
covered in a farm is in it. This is an
old synagogue that has been opened up
over here and cleaned out. This is
probably where Paul taught.
And uh maybe Paul was in the synagogue
inside this. If we go into history,
well, this is the city of Prague
and uh today pretty industrial, but the
ancient city is very very beautiful. One
of the most beautifully preserved old
cities in Europe. Very, very impressive.
This is where Johan Hus preached. And
here's a statue in his memory in front
of these old buildings.
And here is a song which they sang. Now
I can't read uh this check language over
here but in any case this song is
against the king of Babylon. Wow. This
Husite Yan Husse preached against the
king of Babylon
and he preached that this king of
Babylon was taking the place of Jesus
Christ and Husse was declared a heretic
and sentenced to death at the stake.
Thou hast a few names even in Sardas
which are not def have not defiled their
garments and they shall walk with me in
white for they are worthy. Here's the
old bridge over the river in Prague. And
here they used to hang the body parts of
the Hosites who rejected the teachings
of Rome and chose the teachings of the
Bible. So if they were caught, then they
cut off pieces and they hung them here
for all to see. So you'd have a corpse
hanging there, an arm, a leg, a head
dangling to remind you that it was not
worth your while to go contrary to the
teachings of the church of the Middle
Ages. As you cross this bridge today,
you will find the pagan saints there
back in their place. Here's a lady
putting her hand
on this image. You can see how this
bronze image over here is shiny from all
the people who put their hands there
because they believe if they put their
hands there they will receive a special
blessing. This is a a Catholic saint who
apparently died here by being dangling
dangled over the bridge actually was
pulled up so they say and if you put
your hand there you receive a special
blessing. So now you can receive a
blessing through the activities of man.
That's what the Husites were fighting
against. Man's elevation over Christ.
Symbols of sun worship. Uh the signs of
the zodiac. Here is a Jesuit enclave
over there with the letters IHS. Isis
Horus set the Egyptian trinity. The
churches are being modified. Here's a
health resort where you can buy some
healthy foods. There is Martin Luther.
And here on this very stairway, which is
called La Santaala,
Martin Luther got up from his knees and
said, "The just shall live by faith."
You see, this stairway,
it is claimed, was the stairway where
Christ walked when he was sentenced to
death by Pilate. And then one night,
miraculously, the angels took the
stairway from Jerusalem and plonked it
down in Rome. That's how it got to be
there. And then they built this
cathedral around it. And today, if you
go up on it on your knees, you can
receive a special blessing and 90 days
absolution. You can still get it today.
That means for 90 days, you can do
whatever you like and be forgiven ahead
of time. Great system, except that it's
not biblical.
So I looked at these young people and
old people crawling up here trying to
find forgiveness for whatever it is they
had done or wished to do. Isn't that
sad? When all you have to do is look at
Jesus and say, "Here I am, Lord. I am a
sinner. Forgive me." And Jesus will look
down and says, "I do not condemn you. Go
and sin no more." What a wonderful way
of finding forgiveness.
Martin Luther and he said, "Here I
stand. I can do no other. Either it's
the word or it's not the word." By the
way, Martin Luther realized even where
his works were not complete.
But he couldn't do everything. His
followers should have followed on, but
they did not. And there he stood.
And well, that's history. The work was
not completed. And so what happened?
Because Martin Luther couldn't complete
the work, another Christian denomination
rose and said, "Hey, Martin, you missed
out on something
and they started a new denomination and
they followed the new leader who was
maybe called whatever Calvin. They
called themselves Calvinists."
And then someone else discovered, "Hey,
Calvin and Martin, you did not realize
that the Bible teaches something else
over here." You know, and then you have
the Baptists
and they have some more information and
they had it. And the
Lutheran say, "Well, Martin didn't see
that, so neither do we." And the
Calvinists say, "Well, we didn't see
that either, so we're not going to
follow that route."
And then you have White Cliff saying,
"Whoa, you know, here's something great
here that we've discovered in the Bible.
Come Protestant fellows, let's do this."
Hey, no, you better do it on your own.
Form your own denomination. And so what
happened? You have all these Christian
denominations,
each with their doctrines which are
based on the Bible, but each claiming to
have something other from the other that
keeps them separate. Don't we all have
the same Bible? Yes or no? Don't we all
have the same truth if we have one
Bible? Yes or no? Then why so many
denominations? Can't we
find out what the truth is and do it?
Well, then comes Philadelphia 1798 to
1844. Philadelphia means brotherly love.
Atalis II built it because he loved his
brother Emmenus
and it was a gateway through the
mountains. It was an open door.
Well, this is an interesting time
because after the reformation had been
completed, that's when Weld mission
started. Kerry went to India 1793,
Morrison to China 187, Moffett to Africa
1817. British Bible Society started in
1804, American Bible Society 1816. The
word went to the world to the angel of
the church in Philadelphia. brotherly
love. Write these things. Says he that
is holy. He that is true. He that has
the key of David. He that openeth and no
man shutth and shutth and no man
openeth. This is an interesting concept.
Something's opening up and something's
closing down. So God opens the way for
world mission and it goes up. But
there's also something else that's
opening and closing here. There were
gates, doors if you like, between the
compartments of the sanctuary. And when
we come into the next time period, we
will find that we're no longer in the
holy, but in the most holy. Huh?
So Jesus's ministry must have shifted
from the holy to the most holy. But
that's another concept that we won't
deal with in detail. Now, I know thy
works. Behold, I've set before thee an
open door, and no man can shut it. For
thou has little strength, small group,
and has kept my word and has not denied
my name. There's no reproof here. A
small group decides
they will follow Christ in everything,
all truth. What happened in this time
period in history?
Behold, I will make them of the
synagogue of Satan, so there are Satan's
church on the world, which say they are
Jews, Christians, and are not, but do
lie. Behold, I will make them to come
and worship before thy feet, and to know
that I have loved thee. So, here is a
group that finds truth,
and something is being restored because
thou has kept the word of my patience.
back to the word. So obviously something
is being done differently. I also will
keep thee from the hour of temptation.
So they won't be here right at the end.
So it's a period just before the last
groups on earth which shall come upon
the world to try them that dwell upon
the earth. Behold, I come quickly.
Wasn't he said in the previous church, I
am coming
soon.
Now I come quickly. You see that time is
shorter now. So obviously we've moved in
history through time from a time when
he's coming soon. He's when he's coming
is not mentioned to a time when he's
coming soon to a time now when he's
coming quickly. This is before the last
events.
But this group will not go into the
final events because they'll be kept
from the hour of temptation. Hold fast
that which thou hast that no man take
thy crown. Revelation 3:9-11. What
happened in history? Well, if you go to
Philadelphia,
you'll find few ruins of some Bzantine
churches there. It's very middle ages.
And uh this old lady has an interesting
connotation for me. She taught me an
interesting lesson. She gave a big hug
and a kiss to a lady that was very sad
who was being marginalized by everyone
else and gave me a stern look of rebuke.
And uh I remember that look because it
taught me something. It taught me that I
must regard people
as of more value than what they do.
But uh that's a different story for
another time. Him that overcomemeth will
I make a pillar in the temple of my God.
Tremendous. Be part of the save. And he
shall go no more out. Eternal life. And
I will write upon him the name of my
God. God's character will be in him. And
the name of the city of my God, the
character of my people, which is New
Jerusalem, which cometh down from
heaven. Note, not a city with bad sewage
down here on earth. No, it comes down
from heaven from my God, and I will
write upon him my new name. Revelation
3:12. These are great promises to this
church.
So, Philadelphia, a time of renewal,
when the teachings of the Bible were
taken in their fullness again and
combined into one teaching, following
everything in the Bible. The Bible also
went into the whole world with Satan
there trying to confuse the issue and
God's people supposedly there to
represent righteousness and truth. And
then comes the last church
loud.
And if we take the prophecy of Daniel
where the 2,300 day prophecy ends with
uh this interesting date 1844. We'll
have a whole lecture on it. So let's not
get into that. Gets too complicated.
Laitia means nation of judgment. So that
means the last one. This is a antiypical
if you like yon kipu. Christ is in the
most holy now because we've moved from
candlesticks and showbreads and altars
of incense to ark of the covenant. So
he's moved into the next phase a yonipur
a time of judgment.
Very interesting. Now this city Antious
built it and named it after his wife
Ludia.
She was Luis. It was a health resort.
They had eyesolve that they made very
famous one which was called Cirium. So
they were there to give spiritual
eyesight if you like. Was a very wealthy
city was destroyed in AD60 by an
earthquake. Rebuilt with own funds, no
state funds. They were wealthy. They had
it all. And they had a health resort.
Those are the ruins of Laa.
Some of it is still being dug up. Here's
an old amphitheater that's not being
excavated yet. And they had this
fascinating system. Here's an old pipe
system. Notice all this insulation
around these pipes.
Tremendous stuff. They put all these
pipes into this these heavy um systems
and piped the water to this town. Now,
not too far away, there are hot wells,
but there were none in Latitia. So they
piped it here and the water went in hot
and a wonderful feat of engineering.
When it came out at Litia, the water was
no longer hot. It was lukewarm.
If you drank it lukewarm, you got
nauseous and you threw up. If you made
it hot, you could drink it. You know,
like tea, you could drink it. If you
made it ice cold, you could also get it
down. So like today where you have these
salt cures and you drink these waters,
you could get it down. But as it arrived
there, it was lukewarm. Fascinating
story in archaeology. I know thy works
that thou art neither cold nor hot.
I would that thou w
because thou art lukewarm and neither
cold nor hot, I will spew thee out of my
mouth.
Revelation 3:15 and 16.
Notice
that the rebuke is not I will come and
take your candlestick and give it to
someone else.
The rebuke is I will spit you out.
H you see this is the last church on
earth. There's no taking away of the
candlestick.
There's only a spitting out.
So this church goes through to the
kingdom, but those that are lukewarm
will have to be spat out of it. This
church will be shaken and those that do
not conform will be shaken up. So is
this a perfect church? Yes or no? No.
It's pathetic.
Notice that it is lukewarm
and that there is no commendation, only
a rebuke. No commendation whatsoever.
It's the only one that has no
commendation. Nothing.
Not too far away, this Hopouloolis where
they are the really hot springs. But
there it was lukewarm. Today, many, many
health resorts with all these beautiful
calcium carbonate deposits and all these
little hot wells down there are all over
the place. It's a very beautiful place.
They still make healthy food there as
well.
Amphitheaters.
This camel, I think, needs a tooth job.
Because thou sayest, I am rich and
increased with goods, and have need of
nothing, and knowest not that thou art
wretched, miserable, poor, blind, naked.
Wow, this church is in trouble. Here's a
little boy gathering gabber. It's a
little uh substance that is used in the
health industry to take pain away. It's
like an anesthetic.
So even today this area is known for its
health herbs. You see there is a health
message
associated with lauda something for the
physical body but unfortunately
they are rich.
Now is God interested in literal riches?
Yes or no? No. So in what are they rich?
>> Spiritual.
>> Yes, they have biblical knowledge.
They have biblical knowledge. You see
the reformation had not completed the
job. The reformation became fragmented
because of an uncomplete job. Then
Philadelphia time period came along and
the consolidation took place and the
word was again unraveled in all its
fullness and loud
inherited the knowledge.
Here they were they had the knowledge
and what do they do with it?
Sit on it.
And what do they do? They become rich
and increased in goods and have need of
nothing. They start playing church.
The church is supposed to be the light
of the world. But these people play
church.
And they do not know that they are
wretched and miserable and poor,
spiritually poor and blind. They don't
have discernment and they are naked.
They are devoid of Christ.
You see, faith without works is dead.
Whereas works doesn't earn you any
brownie points because you are saved by
grace and grace alone. If you do not
share that which you know, well then you
have a problem. And if you are rich, if
you believe that you have the truth,
well then why share it with someone else
and make might make you uncomfortable.
And there are people that might believe
that they have the truth and that the
truth will save them. The Jews believed
that and they had the truth, but they
rejected the Messiah and nailed him to a
cross. Didn't they do that?
So to have the truth doesn't save you.
To have Jesus Christ saves you. And if
you have Jesus Christ, you will go out
and you will not condemn those who know
not the truth. You will love those who
know not the truth and try and win them
over to the truth because Jesus died for
you and for me while we were yet
sinners, right or wrong?
>> And that's the way it's going to be.
And let me tell you something. Nobody,
and I'm going to say this very harshly,
nobody is saved by his right
understanding of any doctrine.
Have you got there?
If you have the perfect knowledge on how
to be saved, is that going to save you?
No. If you sit on it and you have it and
you're riched and increased in goods,
that's not going to save you. applying
it to the heart and making Jesus the
center and the alpha and the omega of
your life. That
is saving knowledge with works.
But to sit on it won't save you. Now if
you become so riched and increased in
goods that you start
arguing on this issue and that issue and
I have the perfect understanding of this
doctrine and therefore I am right and
you are wrong and you are lost and I'm
saved. This church is so full of
knowledge that it has time to debate the
issue round and round like a dog with
its mouth and its tail running round and
round in circles and getting nowhere.
This church is wretched and miserable.
So if you're looking for the perfect end
time church, you will not find it. You
have to look for one that's miserable
and poor and blind and wretched. Then
you might have found it. How's that? I
counsel thee to buy of me gold tried in
the fire that thou mayest be rich, and
white raignment that thou mayest be
clothed. So how do you get rich? And how
do you get the robes of righteousness?
And how do you cover the shame of your
nakedness? And how do you get spiritual
discernment and I solve so that you can
see?
As many as I love, I rebuke and chase
and be zealous therefore and repent.
So if you want to do what is right, God
will put you in the fire of affliction.
So I have bad news. Anybody
who finds this truth,
it's hot
and you will have to take care of
yourself and eat gerra. Here there's a
knocking on the door and here there is a
beautiful field ready for the harvest. I
took this standing on my knees taking it
across. Behold, I stand at the door and
knock. If any man hear my voice and open
the door, I will come into him. God
doesn't force anyone. And I will s with
him and he with me. To him that
overcomemeth, there's some overcoming to
be done. Will I grant to sit with me in
my throne, even as I also overcame, and
I'm set down with my father in his
throne. Revelation 3:20. That's the
history of the church.
Finally, I have to tell you that there
are people on this earth who have a
knowledge of the truth, but they're not
very well known for spreading it.
They're rather well known for sitting on
it and arguing amongst themselves as to
the particulars of each particular point
and as to their perfection or
non-perfection in this issue or that.
That's not the issue. Jesus is the
issue. Truth is important, but only if
it is applied to the hearts.
And I pray
that we all may understand
and gain a knowledge of the truth,
but that we far more lest we become
clanging symbols, find Jesus, and apply
him to our hearts. In the next lectures,
we will find out
how truth has been thrown to the ground
on this planet and what trouble we are
really in and who controls what and how
they do it. May God bless you and keep
you and come to the next lectures as we
unfold the whole battle between good and
evil. Thank you for coming.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Yeah.
Heat.